hello there reject nation greg and john
here today to watch ed and lorraine
warren prove that a real life murder was
actually the results
of demonic possession with the conjuring
the devil made me
do it i like these movies quite a bit
i've enjoyed
most of this franchise i gotta say for a
[ __ ] franchise you know it's pretty
consistent
and that's cool with quality expectancy
hit that like button if you end up
enjoying our video or just to do it
because i'm asking it helps the video
perform better also subscribe click that
notification bell to get notified
if another video comes up they end up
liking the the
title peaks your interest yeah we'll be
lucky if we get this monetized odds are
it won't be so i
huge thank you to all who show their
support over to us
over at our patreon page this is
reaction highlights can only show us
a little bit of footage of the movie
itself full length reaction watch as
long as we think about the time code for
the conjuring the devil maybe do it
that's a mouthful of the title over at
our patreon page so go check us out over
there we also got
reactions uh we're at the same tier get
the option for reaction highlights and
watch long included
for a wide variety of tv shows these
thumbnails are just a few
lastly thank you to berthom jindal for
editing these highlights for us as
intros under a minute and a half don't
complain at me
you should try and get some sleep yeah
yeah you're coming oh i'll take them mr
glassman
thus the devil gets sleep no time for
sleep
come on buddy got souls to eat things
will move quickly now that the exorcism
has been approved
father gordon's already on his way voter
gordon
being brave doesn't mean you're not
scared
that means you are scared but you hang
in there
it's gonna be all right that's the theme
of the movie that's the theme stated
you're probably checking off those
bullet points
[Music]
the exorcist is a good movie huh it is a
pretty good movie the exorcist
like how there's like this diagonal
shape to where the entrance of the door
is in the pathway yeah so you come in
the corner
oh
it just wants to take a shower
oh no oh
young beverly
what's going on
even ed's like i don't want to go in
there you go first man
[Music]
now if it's actually happened in real
life
is that a child or a small woman okay on
the full armor of god
that we may be able to stand against the
wiles of the devil against the powers of
the darkness of this world against
wickedness oh golly
oh
oh
oh cool what a great shot where's your
first aid
don't talk
take me
oh they just remade the exorcist in 10
minutes
that's efficient
man
[Music]
more of an entertaining pop flavor to
this one huh yeah it's like an
action horror movie
we back i missed that title card
already hardy's fault he the devil made
him do it yeah clear scene
duh he got on tape
i sympathize with that murderer
we're gonna transfer him to the
coronarian so it was a heart attack
yes and not a minor one i'm afraid
can we see a heart attack of biblical
[Laughter]
proportion
so is he gonna be all right oh
that's strange you must have been trying
very hard
you better get one in before you go to
jail man before you commit murder
[Laughter]
i just started this job i can't just up
and walk out now jesus christ
besides bruno doesn't know the first
thing arnie had such high hopes man yeah
yeah
now what's he going off and did terrible
things
let me think about it okay
well think about it think about it she
looks like a
like a cousin or brie larson or
something yeah
i can see that
everything's i said the yeah
that you guys that you guys can't hear
the highlights
you can imagine you fill it in with your
mind
it's the devil dude
always making mischief
some fun cuts in this one i know it's a
punch there's a pop
michael schaub's really making up for
the curse of love
can you bring out the tray with the meat
on it oh yes i'm starving you starving
bud
yep okay i'll go get the meat oh
why'd you do this
oh the devil is so annoying
the devil just drives people so insane
that they kill of their own volition
anything to stop this [ __ ] these are
the thoughts that run through my head
when we're at a theater
put your eye in there
closer be smart get closer
oh it's nothing
man this director would have a great
career on youtube
next step man viral videos that's crypt
tv short films
in high school wasn't it yeah bear 17.
[Music]
i went out with my girlfriends and and
he was an
usher at the movies zack morris
afterwards we went out for ice cream
mcmorris i guess and we stood under the
gazebo
until it stopped
[Music]
that was 30 years ago and then we
summoned a spiritual entity
that's when we knew we were compatible
he pulled out his ouija board
so only ed knows that the demon went
into him that's the sense i get yeah
he's the only one who saw that
and i guess he's chosen to see past that
i can't tell i guess if arnie remembers
this or not john is the
the ghost the ghost no you just love
talking i do
[Music]
what the hell all right you have to call
the glatzels we have to warn them it's
got the kid it's fine it's over
david is safe the demon is gone arnie
it's got arnie
damn it he just made the speaker louder
doesn't he know someone could be calling
he's not gonna kill the dogs is he uh
in a satanic possession movie i wouldn't
put it past it
he's gonna kill that guy right i'm kind
of hoping he dies
or is he gonna kill him both
oh no
this is officer thomas my name is
lorraine warren i
know how this is gonna sound but there's
gonna be a tragedy
what
what in the world just happened
gnarly yeah but we know what happened
you just stay right there okay the
demon's gone
what can you do now who's your lawyer
this is a court of law the standards of
evidence are completely different the
court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth i think it's about time they
accept the existence of the devil
[Music]
you come over to our house for dinner
we'll show you the
evidence we've collected over the years
introduce you to annabelle
if you're not convinced we'll butt out
annabelle
your honor my client pleads not guilty
by reason of
demonic possession the hell you say lady
talking about demon
[Laughter]
i don't need any of that seitan mumbo
jumbo
my courthouse we won't let him down
the stakes just got higher
whoever location scouts these deserves
more credit
cool you can watch tv there
i've always wanted to rip a sheet off of
something like that
i've never felt a waterbed before well
after this you won't want to
oh
weird
that's not water damage
[Music]
this wood is possessed
it's devil poop
so what is possessed well let me handle
this
i'm going to ruin your dress if you go
in there so much more added in the rain
warning this one huh
right from the beginning yeah not even
like waiting to have them called in
yeah but i have it on good authority
they are the heart and soul of this
friendship
you're right you all right yeah i'm fine
ed
it's just a wrap that's two rat scares
[Music]
there's gonna be a third be a rad army
by the end
a rat king
what are so many rats
maybe that lady is a rat lady
what is it i don't know it looks like
jaw bones or
something like stitched together it
looks like the mandalorian sigil
yeah didn't hear the car driving
this guy okay phenomenal and he's a
character actor i know we've seen in a
bunch of stuff
what does this tell you about the person
who made it
that they are a satanist and these guys
are a little fun house collection too
he's got his own cursed doll his baby
was born six weeks early
with its heart outside of its body ah
grossy this boy is headed to the death
chamber
is saving him worth everything you have
because that's what it may very well
cost
no we're driving you guys
there are more cases right let's just
sell our stories to a movie studio
oh nice
so below oh it's that lady's master
satanist
she's the villain
i know who you are it's like a trailer
what is that demon i don't know
this looks like a dude just looks like
yeah like just like a feral person
creepy woman
look what the parent family sent
oh that was sweet of them perrin
wasn't that the name of them in the
first one
katie's body was found near here stabbed
22 times
we still haven't found jessica 22 times
there's a pattern yeah we've been
combing through these fours for over
three months now mrs wong i can see
things that your people can't
what do you mean your people
it becomes a whole different
nice case closed you're the real deal
satan's real everyone
that's why he likes singing elvis hogs
ed yeah
because he gets possessed by health i'm
i'm fine i'm tired you know but
incredibly pale
no keeping something from me
talk to me about it in front of my
brother
who's been through enough afraid she
won't be able to do it
no i'm afraid that you will
dude this detective is like going all
out with his
try to
yeah let's go to the woods now
find where i found that
ah that's cool
whoa
all right that's enough ah [ __ ] she's
trapped
[Music]
i remember the the demon hat thing
grabbing her in the trailer
nope they cg it out
oh must be such a pain in the ass to
find a body in the water
you're one of those big old pool things
just glad we could help let me know
where you're staying
not get that case file to you anymore
yeah
side quest complete
[Laughter]
it's a good thing you hop into the mind
of a possessed
girl gnarly
yeah it's like an eddie ray ward on the
road adventure
[Music]
never checking up on their daughter who
had their own movie
she'll be fine she can handle herself
we saw it
oh what is he is he literally suggesting
that he
kill himself as a means of defeat oh
[Music]
this demon you are so
bleak you know
i got a lot of dark thoughts you guys if
it's jessica
if it's really her then that connection
could still be open
there's got to be another way what are
you talking about man you're connected
to the killer
this is your inn this is what you guys
do
there's got to be another way to find
the killer yeah
not the killer the demon possessor the
entity
[Music]
does he know what he's doing
[Music]
these two are so good in these roles
they're just so damn good
they they are
they bring these two living people to
life yeah
there's such a sincerity in their
performances
i got the body from the river yeah
that's what they're looking for
must have missed that line with my own
thought
ew what a gross thing to do
there's nothing but i jumped scared
the right what is it the connection
the connection is here yeah i guess the
connection between the two cases
ed and lorraine have an arch nemesis now
[Music]
oh
i command that
oh that thing
lorraine
oh no it's a different thing
how's this happening i don't know
all right
[Music]
cool oh
wow
it just got president
what condition does he have i'm not sure
stress no no
are you in the connection
oh that's a good reveal yeah
and it was her
tell her tell them what you're looking
for yeah one of the flower arrangements
huh it's gonna say one of the flower
ranges there's a bunch of flowers
yeah you got one oh boy
it's poor arnie this is really not his
fault
guess not let's hope she didn't try
anything before then
did they ever convict the satanist lady
[Music]
yes this is all true there's so much i
didn't know about our
real life history mm-hmm why the
government just confirmed aliens
i feel so sorry for this guy
[Music]
justice for arnie never forget
[Laughter]
hashtag
yeah but not a lot of train tracks
remember lorraine's vision she said she
heard a train
damn you know the train lions dude
you're so much more than a cameraman
i'm glad your character got an upgrade
he knows
he knows the train schedule because he
rides the train to all these cases
tried calling but we couldn't reach you
we were hoping you'd help us translate a
passage from this book
oh no he's a satanist i hope not but
yeah maybe you never know
oh man
freaking not danny masterson not max
foncito
sir not master city
you forgot your meds
i want you to be right
i want to like this priest not priest
i don't know the same stuff looks cool
man
looks more powerful than where they got
going
look at my lamp it's new in many years
so i raised her here in secret
ah
it was just the two of us his daughter
is the witch
we must be careful
how our obsessions are passed to our
children
the warren girl's gonna be the villain
of the next one
hey man you raise your kid and you're a
basement full of like occult
objects it's bound to happen
it's just iron you know
you're the stupidest priest in this
whole franchise
it's hard to argue so you just let
already's girl just chill at this
freaking prison with the
dangerous you know murder convicts and
stuff yeah
in the dead of night she's here
maybe you should have some light
switches on in this creepy
freaking basement yeah
it goes lower the sub basement
sorry guys this is a little much
[Music]
specifically the country
snap diggity
dude she can like you know project
clones of herself
[Music]
you got mega powers as a girl man
satan vision
this one rated r maybe
i can't tell or the conjurers are
already insidious or pg-13
yes that sounds right
no satan not today
no it's your movie
oh she's like christ it's stirring thee
sacrilegious altar yeah
[Music]
wait is this through a connection or is
she actually there
yes both so daddy's little tunnel
entrance just took her
right there yeah it's pretty close
[Laughter]
but she's actually not traveled too far
yeah muscle car all right
i wish there was like a cool car chasing
this
this is ed has his character arc
of overcoming his heart attacks
that's right man whoa
whoa what the what the what
whoa neat neato that's a cool
shot oh that's oh that's awesome
[Music]
okay
at me oh see if they're a perspective
could always count on a nearby rock
absolutely
mvps movies nearby rocks
i'm still
this is new he has new weapon from now
on in all these movies he's gonna have a
mallet
oh no oh there's like a super different
shot on the trailer yeah
she think morphs
that's not even in this movie
[Music]
we'll figure out how to be scary in post
t
i mean in the trailer cut if you pause
it it really does look like oh you just
laid a quick after effects mask over
there
no no he's doing the body contortions oh
you know it's getting bad
uh here's johnny again yeah
[Music]
moriarty huh
hello
[Music]
[Music]
oh hey maybe you can trick him into
destroying the altar
strength now open your eyes
i see said the blind man
picked up his hammer stuff
up
[Laughter]
nice nice eduardo
oh my god three years later artie was
executed
and meanwhile this priest is over here
be like i did it
from ghostbusters too
you did it ed
where's the creepy lady
you've defeated me this time sherlock
holmes
disappeared in a puffer smoke
your curse is broken
what promised a demon a soul
oh wow
he's like of course
god what is the auditions like for this
it's been that same guy who they get for
all those horror movies
yes javier boat saturday
doug jones is busy get in here we need
your double joints
can you play a small child too
hi i uh
i forgot my pills
[Music]
she carried a pill with her yeah
[Music]
you know she was in the background of
that one scene so she's fine
where where are the cops there
to to arrest the demon but at the cost
get no
none not in the background no valik is
back
the cops get notified i have no idea
that preached out a lot of security on
his property
ah annabelle
those toy soldiers get a spin off
whatever to arty
just let him go right yeah man he's he's
fine
he's innocent literally all the people
at the hospital can attest he was
floating in the
air all the windows exploded
tongues were spoken contortions were
made
so so was her body yep
sorry that's
slightly better than murder
oh not bad all right here you go
oh happy ending
to this day already has not murdered
anyone he hasn't been possessed once
if you're watching this youtube you
can't hear the music
we're not dealing with that crap
it's the same gazebo i had it moved
oh
[Music]
let's have another baby yes bring
another child into this world
to never watch or spend time with
you guys you crazy warrens
warrens woof woof
way to go michael chavez that's great
now listen to the tapes as well as being
there and hearing him do it
he would constantly challenge what was
in that boy the name of jesus
jesus repels you leave this child alone
[Music]
david mom is here i was a real woman
[Music]
these photos just look real i think
they're mixing together yeah
stills from the movie with actual videos
okay
yeah for a second they got me too i was
like really how
oh no i should be in prison
she dies in strip oh wow
this kid all the hill house kids man
are all typecast now
this is a creepy audio i'm sure we're
gonna hear the
longer one on youtube yeah you can hear
the uncut i'm sure there are tons of
those
and then the only trouble is figuring
out which of them are real and which of
them are just people
messing around with cool audio equipment
wow poor ernie yeah
rory o'connor
is is definitely how that's pronounced
i just laughed at first because it's
like
the man's convicted of manslaughter in
real life and this movie takes
totally like takes his side
this movie goes
[Music]
like like you don't understand demon
demons you know we shouldn't
feel like no question about it yeah
it's like doing it freaking like
focusing on the
the people who murdered like sharon tate
and then
there's demon possession oh yeah like
that one movie they made a couple years
ago
that was so that was like sharon tate
being haunted
yeah that's different i'm talking about
like it was about the murderers yeah you
and each of them was possessed you're
possessed
and then the movie just takes a complete
approach to being like see
yeah yeah but you feel like you need to
yeah you feel bad for him being
convicted don't you now
yeah he got convicted of accidental
murder
oh one and two i mean you know
how many times did we enter the
courthouse in this movie like two
and it's also funny it's funny because
out of any of the con the movie is
called the conjuring i'm gonna talk
about the spin-offs and that wacky
[ __ ] the conjuring
this really
it's like the other ones were like okay
based on true story in whatever cases
but this was so
public and then there's like these
public ass settings
like when arnie is possessed in the
hospital room
prison scene i'm just like this is
so ridiculous to try to like hammer in
this is true
at your book at your end real quick
yeah he was happy of the year you would
probably have
literally one of those cinema moments
where like every heart and criminal is
like no we saw that
that's real that's messed up we've
murdered people for
on purpose because that wasn't the same
the people in this show that people on
the other side were
when it was happening yeah like uh like
when the lady said are you going to
clean that
yeah there are people there
like why even try why i even try to
bring in the hell i code and
it becomes a distracting element then
yeah
or it's like the other ones are like
they're in a home you know it was like
maybe
but they're not at home and yeah it's
like you know it's kind of
contained to the family who's
experiencing it so you get that
like very permeating sense of
subjectivity yeah
yeah it's just like now you're just
pulling me out when you try to tell me
this is true yeah
like like it was really trying to grow
that one went a little more ridiculous
than i expected it to
yeah well i'm sitting here going like
okay this whole thing with this other
well this woman with the altar and
everything is that is that
real contrived for this movie it's
like you're supposed to go you should be
like guys this is the third conjuring
movie
in a movie that's already had multiple
spin-offs you know like this isn't true
but the movies try to tell me this like
the movie is going out of its way
in the beginning and end to be like true
yeah based on a true
event this guy was convicted in spite of
clear demon possession
that it makes you now that out of any of
the conjuring of
standalone movies this is the one that's
maybe like the most
questionable and aware of how
distracting the based on true thing is
yeah yeah so yeah
because they they totally take a side
too so that's why
yeah yeah there's like exorcism emily
rhodes like a
sight one example like they let you
wonder
they yeah they present both arguments
um anyway that was fun that was fun
all right drag these mics over here the
devil made me
review it oh very good
so i'm gonna contribute i'm done all
right
look so we just watched it obviously
um i guess i have a hard time
separating myself from the fact of how
this i mean it is based on a on a true
story that did
like on it is based on a public case
right so that was
uh in the media and stuff and um
i have a hard time completely separating
myself
from it which i know that's something
that a lot of people
will be like you got it by this point
like you have
to you have to it's it's just a little
more challenging when
when i feel like the movie itself is
trying to have its cake and eat it too
because it's like you're you're trying
to tell me that
like this is based on a true thing and
you're doing the most
ridiculous non-believable things in the
world
to support this and uh that doesn't
really
work for me uh and that's a big part
it's it's
it's like i i enjoy
i i think you know obviously i think uh
patrick wilson and vera fermiga
are phenomenal actors and they they're
so good in here like there's like
i just love watching them yes their
scenes together
are just every scene with them together
is
great or elevated you know yeah it's
like you said like they are
so so sincere that you can't help but be
endeared to them and their
relationship and and you know for for
better or worse it is the
glue that holds a lot of these movies
together although i do or at least the
ones that they are featured heavily in
uh but i do think that that it it does
something
to this to change their presence to
being sort of
the central presence of the movie
instead of being you know a very
prominent
but uh i feel like in the previous
conjuring movies you spent
a lot of your time with and in the shoes
of the victims of the haunting the
possession etc and then you had
ed and lorraine as this comforting
presence to them but also us the
audience and now at this time
it's not like a bad idea to do it but i
feel like it does
change things to make it so that we are
so heavily locked into their perspective
throughout the movie
well it's they're they're the characters
who are the ones who are supposed to
arguably be having the arks and all that
stuff and
and even though they're great they don't
have an emotional arc
or something to go on rightly no they're
just another case they're solving yeah
they maintain their love and
but that's and that's part of the thing
is is yeah ed and lorraine warren they
come in and they assist
these people and the people have the
arcs exactly they're dealing with
something they don't
know anything about you know and it's
also scarier because
you know ed and lorraine are going to be
fine yeah they're
edwin
and not just because even if they
weren't real people you know the stores
of
the franchise uh but knowing the real
people also
goes against that so much and make you
be scared for them
uh especially in like that finale moment
i'm like well it's gonna be fine
like i just know it's gonna be fun i
don't even like i honestly don't even
know the real case
i don't know anything about the real
case yeah i know i know nothing about it
uh but it's i'm sure if i did a couple
of google searches i'd be like well of
course only
that happened but there's other stuff no
not documented
um but yeah it does take out this
element of fear
when you do know that they're gonna be
fine and
it's hard to make me care about a
guy where i'm aware that in real life
this dude was convicted of well
not murder but man for murdering a man
like in real life i'm aware of that and
i'm and i'm so aware what the movie's
trying to get me to do that it's hard
for me to just buy into the
solely the narrative of the movie and
completely detach myself from
the though the real life it's like this
movie relies
on you as an audience member believing
in demon possessions and all that's like
what if you if you don't
then it's like it's going to be like
what a messed up movie you know well
that's the thing is every conjuring that
comes out there is a certain amount of
people out there who do
who are vocal about hey you know ed and
lorraine warren they don't have
you know an entirely agreeable public
persona and there's some people out
there who think that they are frauds and
hacks and people who prey on other
people and so
there i feel like it you know for
blockbuster purposes it's fine but
uh if you know if you are going to hang
your hat on that
true life element it does seem like you
can't go
just full-on fantasy because then it
does kind of seem like you're just
glorifying a fantasy
rather than confronting i don't know
like i feel like it would be some kind
of an asset to the franchise to at least
acknowledge you know that i guess in
you know that skepticism from a certain
group of people out there
uh you know when adapting these stories
about these real life
people at least who you know dealt with
you know
hard to explain scenarios well
it's a completely different asking of
your audience whether you're a believer
or not
it's a completely different task to ask
that of your audience
when you're dealing with like children
in trouble in a home
not a criminal
not a man who is convicted of murdering
someone that's a it's a completely
different
uh discussion at that point because they
do
even in the real life interview during
the credits when they say how does this
go to all cases when suddenly you're
saying like the devil made me do it
when you say something everyone could
just jump in like that that's a great
question i wish the movie explored this
yeah and i don't want to be that guy
necessarily however
you know judging off the trailer we got
this impression
like they used all of the courtroom
footage in the trailer that's actually
in the movie because you know we were
sitting there going like oh maybe
there's going to be sort of an exorcism
of emily rose slant on this or some kind
of
probing at the legal aspect and and
seeing
what the court makes of this and there's
none of that in the movie and i feel
like that is also kind of a missed
opportunity to
if not legitimize at least explore
the other side because yeah it really
does like when the lawyer
who needed convincing looks over them
she's like you know there's a long stare
of like
you gotta prove to everyone that the
demon possession is real
you know i i feel like they take off
into fantasy
to a degree that yeah does kind of just
[ __ ] on the toes of the whole true
story aspect
well i think the okay so then you have
to do the thing
there's people who are going to go well
you guys are getting too caught up in
the
whole trip i'm like it's not my fault
the movie's doing it
the movie's telling you to get to
believe it
yeah all right so okay i'll play ball
let's take that out of the equation
let's
uh let's just go all right i've accepted
the fact that this movie is just so
fiction and i'm just gonna take the
story for what it
is it's like when people get mad at like
it's like how people got mad at cruella
for like this doesn't really lead into
the 101 dalmatians character that i know
and students don't think like no like
that purity argument yeah
like all right so
let's let's just i'll remove myself from
that and just go what the movie is
itself the movie itself
i thought um i was the first few minutes
i was like oh this is gonna be a very
different movie
um it was so out there and so wild and
so
like visceral and freaking like horror
movie
kid contortions and stuff yeah it was so
big right away
yeah whereas the other ones are not that
grandiose immediately and then you're
getting like
vision like they're doing your whole
setup right there in the beginning and
oh
i believe i don't remember what the
opening of the second one is
uh but i but i remember the first one
it's annabelle so you you're not
you you do like a separate case then you
check in with your family
and then the warrens eventually come in
so that's how it happens you really
invest in the family so here it's like
no you're the people we're opening with
that's who we're staying with
yeah the whole time and you're really
gonna um
this is the case you're following and
then ed and lorraine warren are the ones
we're gonna
we're gonna be having a hard time
dealing with this case as well and so
the first like
uh 40 minutes i'd say i was i was
enjoying it quite a bit actually i was
like this is
super entertaining you know it's fun
it's really fun and i was able to just
get on board with how fictitious all
this
is and visually it's so from beginning
to end visually it's so well done
there's some really cool
yeah stylistic flourishes beautiful
lighting
beautiful shadow work beautiful gaming
all that
yeah it was it was really cool and even
the scene when he murdered
uh the guy was pretty sweet in the way
it was handled you know
it's really cool sorry for those who
care about
the actual real life victim in this
situation
but if i'm going through the discussion
of just purely
fiction just as a movie this is a
fantasy neatly done it's really well
handled and spooky
and what i was never i never had a scene
see so i mean there were like moments
that were a little tense
there were moments that were a little
spooky and scary or i watch it and go
that's cool like like in uh the morgue
yeah i thought that was cool how that
was done or when the little boy's being
carried away and
there's like scratches appearing on the
wall at the beginning of the movie or
the contortion scenes
those are all cool and intermittently
cringy or scary
but there wasn't ever a full scene where
i was just
on edge and i thought that the first 30
to 40 minutes were entertaining
then it started to go into uh i don't
know there were times where i was a
little bit bored but i couldn't really
tell where
but the last like hour of this movie
really started to lose me
a lot uh i was really starting to check
out
when it was now about their like
we can't make the real bad guy in real
life be the villain we gotta sympathize
with him
we're gonna bring in a witch lady yeah
yeah we're gonna make which lady this
big spooky baddie and
this is the daughter i was like
this is just getting so contrived it's
getting
convoluted yes it's so it got too
ridiculous for me
again on a movie that's trying to sell
you that this is real
that this is based on true things let's
remove that
if we remove that i still think it's
ridiculous
i still think it goes a little like way
too out there like
you mean like this priest just happened
to have this one daughter who's doing
this and then his little tunnel leads
right to her alternative yeah yeah this
is silly he's
stupid yeah and the and ed and ray
warren are the main characters
yeah they're not the main supporting
characters who are also the lead kind of
like
pirates of the caribbean johnny depp is
the lead but
the character journeys are like orlando
bloom and karen i don't know why my
mind went there as an example but that's
what it is and then the con
this one that's how the other conjuring
movies worked and then this one
they're the main characters and i'm like
well as in terms of storytelling
you gotta have a little bit of an arc or
something like that i don't know what
the um like what arc is there for them
you know it's like how did this
experience
truly affect or change them was she mad
about not living like their early days
so we got the gazebo for them like
what is the what's the journey here
exactly
you know i love exciting hanging out
with them exploring them and i think
they're so fun
they're fantastic actors and uh i love
being with them but
as a just as a movie itself i i do think
that
it is the weakest of the three conjuring
movies i don't know where i'd rank it in
the conjuring universe
it's better than majority of their
spin-offs
i personally had more fun and enjoyed
the third annabelle movie more because
that one i really this one i felt like
was kind of at war with itself of what
it
really wanted to be yeah it's like
you're going bonkers but you're not
allowing yourself the like unrestrained
energy that going bonkers really
requires if you're going to
sell that and again not have it create
dissonance with this whole sort of
historical fiction aspect
yeah uh and yeah like it did start to
crest for me into
i started to think of an insidious movie
rather than a conjuring movie at a
certain point
um and yeah i i i feel like i'm with you
overall
i think i might maybe enjoy the
experience of it a little bit more like
i think
that's usually how it goes i mean yeah
like it's i think it's
it's well done and everybody on screen
is really committed to the point
that even scenes i don't like have
something in them where i'm like well
there's some really great filmmaking and
really great performance work on display
but i
i yeah i can't really argue against the
fact that it does after a while
start to kind of couch and use the
arnie's story
just as set pieces for spooky stuff to
happen
and to enhance this element of like oh
there's this crazy lady pulling all the
strings and look arnie's going through
this while she's doing a ritual
here and you know i feel like part of
the charm of the conjuring movies is to
zero in on the victims to some degree
even if we are
fictionalizing a lot of stuff and you
can argue for days about how respectful
or not it is to do that
um and i i feel like here though it it
does
at least in a spiritual sense who's out
yeah you should have committed to your
arty storyline instead of like making me
forget about this
artist yeah yeah it's like putting all
the blame on this
witch lady and i feel like you could
have done all the bonkers cool fun
haunting stuff you wanted to and still
had a a rich or at least conflicted
character story surrounding arnie
whereas after
a point uh you know after you know the
first act basically it becomes yeah the
warren's movie and then he gets
sidelined and then
yeah i feel like there are misstopper
tune like i would put this in the middle
of the conjuring franchise right
now like as a haunted house movie big
blockbuster
you know fright fest i think it's a
solid good enjoyable
movie experience but yeah the spiritual
side of just you know how it's
portraying itself and how it is
uh uh you know sharing the focus between
all the story lines and
yeah like arcing any characters at all
you know nobody really has an arc in
this movie i don't i don't think except
for the the cameraman gets
to help out with the investigation yeah
see like with arnie i was like well you
could have it's just an interesting
exploration of something then if you're
gonna make him a character you
sympathize with
you know he's clearly a religious man
and he clearly believes in the whole
demon stuff
right um you could have had a thing
where where it's like he's having a
conversation
with girlfriend character
is having a conversation with her and
is saying that i was possessed
it wasn't me but it was still at my own
hands so i feel like i should
still maybe go to jail i should still
be sentenced because it was my own hands
and i need penance for that
and i can't live with myself knowing
walking the streets that this man died
in my own houses because i had an
interesting line there of like
the devil like the devil went into me i
don't know if he said the devil he's
like they went into me because i invited
it into me so this is still my fault
yeah you know like let's do some with
like
some of those conversations then you
could get something kind of interesting
happening here
and then that way i think you can kind
of
do both both sides of it of go no he's
still responsible
but he in his world of the movie he's
not fully responsible you know what i
mean
you know i'm trying to get i don't know
you could make the argument much
more nuanced and much grayer because i
don't know i mean like if this
story was notable enough to make a movie
out of it all it must have some
compelling gray areas to it yeah and it
must have been a big struggle for the
people close to
this guy who have to take it on faith
that he
really was in some altar say like i feel
like you could have used
some flesh to that even especially for
you know his girlfriend whose little
brother was possessed
you know in the prologue and and it i
guess the the
it started off with the flag because
once the prologue was done arnie invites
the spirit in
at first i was like did he forget about
that
because in you know when things reset
and they go back to normal for a few
minutes before he commits the actual
murder and stuff like that
you know it seems like he forgot until
he acknowledges like no i invited the
spirit in
um and so i don't know exactly where i
was going with that but it feels like
yeah there's some aspect
that isn't fully like thought out or
clicked in as to how they chose to
handle him
see i think i hold the standalone
conjuring movies to a higher standard
than the spin-off movies that's just the
reality of it
and yeah i think most people do for for
good reason because you can rely
on the ones called the conjuring all the
other ones are dice rolls
yeah yeah and uh so yeah i mean this one
to me
oh like that's what i mean it was it's
weird to me because when i look back at
my my time sitting here in the first
like 45 minutes
or 30 to 45 minutes i was i was enjoying
it i was having fun with it
uh but then something in that last hour
just like not something with some things
like while there was some intermittent
stuff there that i was enjoying
when ed and lorraine warren are
separated
not a big fan of it and then when it got
when it gets
too big throughout because i feel like
the conjuring movies
the other two at least progressively get
bigger as they go yeah it takes a while
to get to like the floating chair in the
first year
or the crooked man like the crooked
man's ridiculous but it takes a while to
get there
oh yeah like conjuring two has an
insanely huge finale
you know like that's that's really big
um
explosions and all right so uh but but
they at least build there we're here
it's just like kind of
non-stop telepath communication invasion
of home
uh infection of the mind manipulation of
which
like once you get like supernatural
which villain in there
like ah you've kind of gone a little
overboard for my taste
especially because that kind of like
which none of the witch lady's not even
scary like she's not she's terrifying
because you know like oh it's just a
person it's just
it's just a witch lady it's just
something yeah some
statements fanatic who is doing these
rituals and casting these curses
we can stop this person whereas like
when it's a demon you gotta be like i
don't know
how you finish now yeah yeah ed lauren
yeah do your thing i guess you know yeah
it wasn't
uh i think that what they were going for
and trying to build
and expand upon and you know i like the
different direction
initial like initially of just taking
them on the road and then like i'm
having to talk to cops and have to
convince the cops of what they do is
actually
you know real and like that one
detective guy
who was just kept taking a skepticism
gamble on them
it was was interesting uh
and but i still even there i'm like that
much
i mean yeah they got the connection and
all that but
like there are threads here that i would
have liked to have seen
some type of
some type of tie up or on or a bow
around it
would the detective maybe like really
not just having credits
uh or talking about the couple like you
made the couple of artie and his
girlfriend like a real couple in this
movie
their characters and not just chalk it
up to some like
text about what happened in real life
with them like okay let's
i don't know do you see something
anything yeah
it there's it wanted to just have the
there's a lot of stylistic stuff with
the thrills and everything i'm sure this
is better than the curse of
your own i've never seen that movie but
i'm sure it's better than that
uh and uh yeah it's like it just really
depends on the standard you're comparing
it to that's
the thing is you know there are a lot of
people like it's better than a lot of
other horror movies out there
true very true it's better than a lot of
the conjuring movies
in the universe true that's very true
does that mean i have to like it no
and i i don't oh overall i thought like
uh you just went too much into stupid
territory for me
in terms of storytelling yeah i think
you did yeah i think
for me like overall a lot of the again
construction
elements and the performance elements
and like a lot of the talent surrounding
the movie i think is actually really
good there's a lot in here that at least
on a construction level and even from a
writing state like regardless of a lot
of the gripes
for what is here i've seen way worse
written movies in this franchise alone
you know like it sells itself i think
relatively well but i do think that
yeah there is a certain element of
especially making it clear it's like you
know you got
we have a clear antagonist and it's
pretty a and b
of we gotta take this person out to
solve everything yeah and the rest of
the world you know
if they don't see it and they don't
believe it then they'll convict this guy
whatever but we know
uh that yeah is a bit of a sort of a
wacky thing to do
with the story that is so grim and it
has
i think more than perhaps the previous
warren stories adapted people going wait
a minute
like this is real and grim and it it
it seems yeah like it doubles down on
the amount of fantasy it wants to pitch
you on
for the amount of all this is true they
always do in these movies
if they're like arguing demonic case
possession i'm like you think they bring
up all this witch ladies stuff to them
yeah because that just doesn't yeah
nothing happens with that once they
vanquish her and so i'm like
what did this help in court did anything
happen in court where you got like did
you
you like what happened to actual arnie
aside from these haunted
these couple haunting moments that we
saw yeah you know
yeah i mean i guess script-wise
fine there's nothing really there's
nothing that popped out to me in terms
of the script
i mean i think the overall way the movie
flow like the choices they made just did
a lot of just wasn't clicking with me
but i never was there like going what a
stupid line of dialogue
i never said that yeah i wasn't like oh
god what what
wrote dialogue you know i've never had
that moment even if i wasn't
always grooving on an idea like the
scenes breathed
they had enough you know life and
personality and and chances for the
actors to
you know really strut their stuff uh
we're gonna get a spin off of that
big old rotund zombie guy
are we i don't know this was the least
spin-off-able conjuring though because i
was like i mean
and it's like it's things like that i'm
torn because i'm like on the one hand i
thought they made some cool stuff out of
that sequence and they got like this
really
big dude who i'm not used to seeing in
this kind of set piece but at the same
time i'm like
okay but in the just what you're
factually telling me at the moment is
that this you know
this lady or he reanimated a zombie
corpse to just
charge it at warren a bunch of times and
then she transported him out of the
morgue and had it happen again
the rules of the rules that you play by
are very confused
are not con they're confusing when you
think about it and
i i think uh yeah i forgot where i was
going with that i i totally lost my true
thought
yeah i don't think that but you you
bring up a solid point about that
it's uh it's weird it's it's
like in the nuts and bolts of that in
the moment yeah it's like in the
superficial i guess i'm like oh neat
that's interesting and new there's a lot
of like
i think that's the difference i guess
for me is there's a lot of this movie i
like
superficially and a lot i take an issue
with subtextually
that my point is this is what is exactly
what you're talking about
i think from uh what i'm seeing with my
eyes
and observation of logistically and
technicality of
just seeing it i'm like cool that's cool
everything is really cool it's
good feeling wise like
how the movie makes me feel impact is
almost
it ranges from amusing to
kind of scared or cringy to oh that's
cool too i'm bored to stupid
like yeah but i've never like i don't
know there's the the conjuring one and
two
do bring like a a grip out of me and
just read
yeah and and like there are scenes that
are just so
tense and then chilling and emotionally
like
like the heart and and this to me
the heart is there because because vera
for fermiga and patrick
wilson are just amazing ass actors
and uh and like there are some scenes
that i you know i think are
done well with with the display of heart
uh but overall like the emotion given to
me i've
like it was
i don't know i never felt anything so
there's nothing i felt strongly about
yeah and i think too it's got to do with
you again going back to the
the arne johnson story what occurred to
me too is with all the other conjuring
movies even in the midst
of the hauntings possessions you get
quiet
moments where that's not happening at
the moment and we
haven't playing guitar playing guitar or
even just a quiet moment between
whatever mom and her kids or whatever
exactly those moments that then
shock like you know lull you into the
heart of the story and then
enhance the shock when you're pulled out
because you don't want to be pulled out
by the demonic stuff
even though you want the thrills as a
movie view yeah and so we don't get that
tension here is you get all the thrills
but there's not much after he commits
the murder
for us to be like ah damn i i really
don't want this lovely human moment to
be interrupted by demons
you know i think there's a lot of cool
youtube short films in here
seriously that's how i view it like a
really great camera trick the camera
tricks the whole thing with like the
mirror stuff
and and the tunnel at the end like that
was great stuff there's a lot of really
cool like youtube short films in this
jam packed in this movie dude knows how
to shoot his chilling moments yes yeah
but uh the the overall feature it
doesn't quite
make a a solid package for me i i
probably give it like a
60 to 65 percent
if i were to give a grading sale out of
a hundred which is not
still passable technically give it like
a 73
on my tomatoes you're always hired you
know i don't think in the entire time
give it a 40. i've never heard you go
lower than me in my time
all right that's my goal now i mean i'm
not i gotta find the movie that
i like less than greg i certainly
probably enjoyed this
at least to smush more than you did but
we'll find that i
had fun because i'm here with you unable
to crack jokes we've had
we've had moon i think in a theater i
would be more
bored with this movie to be honest
because i can't [ __ ] just
look at you and tell you what i think
it's dumb yeah and so in that
environment then when it's doing
when it gets to that point where you're
like okay we got some conjuring stuff to
do
i know what we're probably gonna have to
do in the action so i'm just kind of
waiting for you know this conclusion to
come up
yeah i can see that yeah having some
wear
in the theaters maybe but also i could
see this being a bit more
fun with a crowd depending because it
does get bonkers it does go like
insidious too on you yeah but it starts
losing its effect
yeah and the other thing is i like
insidious movies a lot but at the same
time i'm like i
i don't the point of james one having a
different ghost franchises so that this
one
isn't insidious you know it's not just
r rated insidious all right guys
well conjuring the devil made me do it
what'd you guys think did you enjoy
yourselves overall i have fun watching
it i'm probably never going to revisit
it
yeah now we're going to go watch
annabelle
i've never i i'm
i'm way more inclined to watch the first
two again than i but i'm never i'm
probably never going to watch this i had
fun for while i was watching it um
but leave your thoughts down below uh
always interested to know what you guys
got to say
and hey let's do up
there's one man or a patreon who likes
horror it's eric horstmann likes horror
horrorst men is your new name
and if there's anybody out there who i
would be a-okay
possessing my body and taking it for a
ride it's you eric
i can't imagine where i might wake up
after a demon possession
brought on by you i can't imagine all
the fun i might have
i i i that's the way i would like to
meet you is if you possess my body you
get me to travel all the way across the
country he's in georgia
he's still is he in georgia he's in
atlanta hotlanta ga that's where i'm
gonna meet you
we're gonna sip some mint juleps or
something
and uh hey if there's anyone you don't
like
you should make commends with them
because this is based on your story and
i'm not going to joke that way
so eric i hope you enjoyed this maybe a
little more than we enjoyed it
um and you're a beautiful sexy man and i
just i
i love you and i miss seeing your we're
never gonna see you on the stardust
again
we'll see you here hello elsewhere i
don't know
i'm just saying stuff to eric literally
get out of here greg this is just me and
eric's time it's like you're trying to
have a conversation with a son you don't
know how to talk to her
you know each shout out's a little
different for me
each one's a little off-road but eric
you inspire me
and this is what you inspire it looks
good now thanks eric